compassion is a reflex not a virtue you
don't think judicious compassion is a
virtue the only way that we can beat
Evil and there is a lot of evil out
there is is by being good right truth is
the thing that is going to set us fre
set us free so not just worshiping and
not just being comp no matter what he
says we're just going to love it right
we're just going to bow to him all the
time not just being compassionate all
the time we are going to have to
actually stand up straight with our
shoulders back get a backbone like a ram
rod and and actually do something true
Jordan Peterson ladies and gentlemen so
you don't think that that came from a
place of compassion I don't care comp I
don't regard compassion as a virtue
compassion is a reflex not a virtue you
don't think judicious compassion is a
virtue wait wait a minute wait a minute
compassion can come
deep from the human heart and the human
mind I think are we talking about the
same kind of compassion trying to
understand the suffering treating adults
like infants is not virtuous I I see but
you you well compassion isn't treating
adults like in I mean those are just
terms are you sure okay I whatever the
term is maybe love is compassion is I
mean I suppose I'm speaking to love you
don't think those ideas came from
concern
compassion you don't think love is a
blend of compassion and encouragement
and Truth Love's complicated man I love
you if I love you is it Compassion or
encouragement you want from me yeah it's
a dance love love is definitely a dance
of two two humans ultimately that leads
to the growth of both well that's the
thing the growth element is crucial yeah
because the growth element to Foster the
growth element that requires
judgment compassion and judgment well
even and have been conceptualized this
way forever two hands of God mercy and
Justice they have to operate in tandem
right and mercy is
flawed as you are you're
acceptable it's like well do you want
that do you want your flaws to be
acceptable and the answer to that is no
it's so it's like well that's where the
Judgment comes in it's like but you
could be better you could be more than
you are and that's the maternal and the
paternal in some fundamental sense and
that is exactly what we need from Trump
right now Trump will not get better by
worshiping him if we all just oh my God
he did it again let's get on the Trump
train let's destroy everybody and that
will not make any of this better you
know what will make some of this better
how about compassion right with a little
judgment and how about some truth
wouldn't that be something if we pushed
him that way that might be something and
then we could get out of this and I
actually think he has it in him I think
he knows how to fight and sometimes what
I would argue is an absolutely
disgusting manner right the things he
has said about DeSantis and the lies
about Florida the place that he and his
entire family live and all of that stuff
absolutely disgusting the way he
manipulated people millions of people
who now hate Ronda santis who who knew
he was the best governor governor in
America a year ago right so there's all
the disuss stuff there but with a little
compassion a little judgment and a
little truth I know that Donald Trump
can be better because he's a little
closer to something honest and real than
anyone on the other side and he does
have some of those inklings you might
remember this from a week ago his town
hall a lot of time talking about
retribution and so there are questions
about how much a second term of a Donald
Trump presidency second term would be
about retribution and looking backwards
and Grievances and how much would be
looking forward well first of all a lot
of people would say that that's not so
bad look what they did Russia Russia
Russia hoax the FBI Twitter hoax the 51
intelligence agents hoax all of these
different hoaxes that they did I mean I
mean you know a lot of people would say
that's probably quite normal I'm not
going to have time for Retribution we're
going to make this country so successful
again I'm not going to have time for
retri that's it right there right don't
run now on retribution and I'm going to
jail everybody and I'm angry at
everybody and everything else right it
looks like you're going to get this
nomination fairly easily there's the
court cases and everything else but
success is the ultimate winner here
right success for the country is the
retribution which I understand why you
might want to a little bit of
Retribution but I now think it is on us
to build Trump up so that he can be the
best version of himself as opposed to
the golden calf version of himself that
many people want to
worship